hi everyone
this is professor mda science and today
i want to derive
the mathematical form of the wave
function of coherent states
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics coherence states are
defined as
the eigenstates of the lowering operator
of the quantum harmonic oscillator
another important feature
is that coherent states are the quantum
states that most
closely resemble the motion of a
classical harmonic oscillator and for
this reason
they're also called quasi-classical
states the aim of this video is really
straightforward we're going to derive
the mathematical form of the wave
function
of coherent states and although today's
focus is on the maths we have
a companion video where we explore all
of the properties of the coherent state
wave functions that we're going to
derive today
so make sure you take a look let's go
let's start with a quick refresher of
the quantum harmonic oscillator
the hamiltonian h is equal to the usual
kinetic energy
plus the potential energy which depends
quadratically on the position operator
we can also write this down in terms of
ladder operators
or in terms of the number operator
the eigenvalue equation for the
hamiltonian is given by
this expression where as usual these are
the eigenvalues
and these are the eigenstates the
eigenvalues en
are quantized and
n is a non-negative integer
the ladder operators allow us to move
between eigenstates
the lowering operator a acting on energy
eigenstate
n gives another eigenstate where there
is one fewer quantum of energy
and the raising operator acting on the
same energy eigenstate
gives another eigenstate with one extra
quantum of energy
visit it for the very quick refresher
but you can find many more details in
our series on the quantum harmonic
oscillator
that is linked in the description
let's now have a quick look at coherent
states
which we typically label with the kit
alpha
they are defined as the eigen states of
the lowering operator
as usual these here are the eigenvalues
and
these are the eigenstates as the
lowering operator is
not emission the eigenvalues are in
general complex numbers
we can actually write coherent states in
a variety of alternative but equivalent
forms
but the one that we will use today
builds on the displacement operator
the displacement operator d alpha is
defined as the exponential function of
this sum over ladder operators
we can then write the coherent state
alpha as equal to the action of the
displacement operator
on the ground state of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
and this expression is the one we will
use today
to construct the wave function
associated with
coherent states again you can find
many more details about all of these
concepts by following the relevant links
in the description
the objective of today's video is to go
over the mathematical derivation that
will allow us to write
the wave function associated with
coherent states
to do so what we essentially need is to
write quantum states in the position
representation
remember that the position basis is
defined through the eigen states of the
position operator
we can then write a general quantum
state psi
using the usual expansion in the
position representation
the expansion coefficients psi of x are
given by the bracket
x psi and these expansion coefficients
are what we call the wave function
in our case we want the coherent state
wave function
and we're going to call it psi alpha of
x
and it is given by the bracket between x
and alpha
as we anticipated a moment ago we'll use
the expression for
alpha up here in terms of the
displacement operator
so we can rewrite this as the brex the
displacement operator
and the ground state kit
so the aim of today's video is to
evaluate an explicit expression
for this wave function and this means
that today's video is going to be rather
mathematical
but don't forget to check out the
companion video where we explore the
various properties of the wave function
of coherent states
with the aim of gaining a more
conceptual understanding of it
to get started with the calculation
we'll first rewrite the displacement
operator in terms of the position and
momentum operators
this here is the definition of the
displacement operator which depends on
the ladder operators here
and here remember from the video on
ladder operators that the lowering
operator
is equal to this pre-factor times the
position operator
plus this pre-factor times the momentum
operator
in a similar manner we can construct the
raising operator
by simply calculating the add joint of
the expression for the lowering operator
let's now take this exponent up here and
let's copy it down
we can rewrite it in terms of the
position and momentum operators by first
replacing the raising operator
with the corresponding expression
and then replacing the lowering operator
with the corresponding expression
we can then combine the two terms with
the position operator
and the two terms with the momentum
operator
overall this means that we can rewrite
the displacement operator
as equal to this exponential in terms of
the position operator
and the momentum operator
we now need to remember a result that
was first introduced in the video on
functions of operators
if we have two operators a and b such
that a
commutes with their commutator and b
also commutes with their commutator then
we have that the exponential of a plus b
is equal to the exponential of a times
the exponential of b
times an exponential of their commutator
in our case the exponential involves the
position and momentum appraises
we have that x and p obey the canonical
computation relation
which means that the commutator is the
scalar i h bar
this implies that x commutes with the
commutator
of x and p and so does p
in turn this means that the conditions
under which this expression holds
are fulfilled so we can use it for our
expression of the displacement operator
up here in particular we get that the
displacement operator is equal to an
exponential of the position operator
times an exponential of the momentum
operator
times an exponential proportional to the
commutator of the position term
with the momentum term
and feel free to pause here to make sure
that you are happy with this sip
moving on let's first focus on this
commutator
to evaluate it we can take all of the
scalars outside
multiplying the commutator of x and p
this commutator is i h bar
this product is equal to alpha squared
minus
alpha star squared the masses cancel
here
and here and the frequencies also cancel
here
and here this means that the expression
simplifies to
minus i over 2h bar multiplying alpha
squared
minus alpha star squared all multiplying
i h bar
the h bars cancel here and here and
the minus i here combines with the i
here to give one
we end up with one half times alpha
squared
minus alpha star squared using this
expression we can now
rewrite the displacement operator as
equal to the exponential of the position
operator
times the exponential of the momentum
operator
times the scalar exponential where we
now use the simplified expression
that we got from the commutator
we're now ready to go back to our wave
function
using this expression for the
displacement operator and inserting it
here
we end up with the wave function of the
coherence state being equal to this
scalar exponential
times the briar x then the exponential
of the position operator
times the exponential of the momentum
operator
all acting on the ground state of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
as the position operator here is
hermitian it can act on this bra
which is a position eigenstate so these
terms simply give the bra
times the scalar exponential
just to make sure this step is crystal
clear this
x here is now a scalar the eigenvalue of
the position i can state here
overall this means that we can rewrite
the wave function
as equal to the original scalar
exponential
multiplying the new scalar exponential
that depends on the eigenvalue
x and all multiplying this bracket that
now
only involves the exponential of the
momentum operator
for the next step we need to use the
translation operator
remember from the video on translation
operators that you have linked in the
description
that a translation by lambda is
described by the unitary operator
t lambda which is equal to the
exponential of
minus i lambda p over h bar
the action of the translation operator
on a position eigen state
is to translate it by an amount lambda
the equivalent equation in geospace
becomes this
we can now see that this exponential up
here is simply a translation operator
where the translation is given by this
prefactor times alpha plus alpha star
this means that the bra x times this
exponential of the momentum operator
is equal to the briar x displaced by the
negative
of the translation
overall we can write the wave function
of a coherent state as equal to this
scalar exponential
times this other scalar exponential
times this bracket between the displaced
position eigenstate
and the ground state
remembering that this here is the ground
state of the quantum harmonic oscillator
then this bracket is simply the ground
state wave function
of the quantum harmonic oscillator which
i label with psi 0
and it is evaluated at x minus the
translation
this means that we can write the wave
function of a coherent state
as equal to this exponential
times this other exponential
times a displaced ground state of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
in the video on quasi-classical states
that you have linked in the description
we show that the expectation value of
the precision operator in a coherent
state
is equal to this pre-factor times alpha
plus
alpha star and we also discussed that
the expectation value of the momentum
operator in a coherent state
is equal to this pre-factor times alpha
minus alpha star
using these results we see straight away
that
this term here is simply the expectation
value of the position operator
and we can also consider this exponent
here which we can conveniently rewrite
like this
feel free to stop here for a moment to
convince yourself of this step
we now see that the term in brackets is
equal to the expectation value of the
momentum operator here
so we can rewrite this as equal to i
over h bar
times the expectation value of the
momentum operator times x
overall we end up with the wave function
of a coherent state
as equal to this exponential
times this exponential times the ground
state of the quantum harmonic oscillator
shifted by the expectation value of the
position operator
in this video we will stick with the
mathematical derivation
but with this latest expression you can
already start to appreciate
some of the interesting properties of
coherent state wave functions
for example the fact that it is a simple
shift of the ground state
but for all the details don't forget to
check out the companion video
so how about the other terms let's look
at
the first exponent from the general
properties of complex numbers
we can write that the exponent is equal
to minus
i times the real part of alpha times the
imaginary part of alpha
i haven't really proved this but it is a
very easy relation to proof by just
using the general properties of complex
numbers
so i leave it as an exercise for you
what we're going to do next is to define
a new quantity
theta alpha as equal to minus the real
part of alpha times the imaginary part
of
alpha as such theta alpha is a real
number
and with this definition the exponent
becomes
i theta alpha this leaves us with the
wave function of the coherent state
equal to this exponential times this
exponential
times the displaced ground state
and we're done but before we finish
let's summarize
a coherent state is the state of the
quantum harmonic oscillator that we
typically label with the kit alpha
it is defined as an eigenstate of the
lowering operator with eigenvalue alpha
what we found today is that we can write
coherent states
in the position representation via their
wave function
which we label psi alpha of x
this coherent state wave function is
given by the product of this first
exponential
times this second exponential times the
displaced ground state wave function of
the quantum harmonic oscillator
in this expression the phase theta alpha
is equal to minus the real part of alpha
times the imaginary part of alpha
the expectation value of the momentum
operator in state alpha
is equal to this pre-factor
times alpha minus alpha star and the
expectation value of the position
operator in state alpha
is equal to this other pre-factor times
alpha plus
alpha star we will leave it here today
but we can actually learn a great deal
about coherent states by investigating
the properties of
this wave function and this is why i
want to encourage you once again to
check out the companion video
where we approach this wave function
from a more conceptual point of view
this type of mathematical derivation is
an essential prerequisite before we can
explore the properties of the coherent
state wave functions
now that we've gone through this
elevation it means that we're ready to
check out the companion video where
among
other things we're going to see how
these wave functions
oscillate back and forth and as always
if you liked the video please subscribe